it took until Friday but we have got the
feel-good story of the week as crime
surges around the country a poor little
old grandmother was about to get into
her car to drive to a chemotherapy
appointment when a teenage criminal
accosted her threatened her with a gun
and tried to steal her car that's not
the feel-good part that that is
obviously all terrible what makes this
the feel-good story of the week is what
happened next
next thing I know he walked up talking
about give me your keys I got a gun I
said baby you better shoot me because
you not taking my car today he pushed me
through the door and I got up and I
grabbed him and was hitting his ass and
hitting them and fighting them and I
said you're not gonna take my car the
younger grandma said when she screamed a
grandson and neighbors came running and
they all came out to help me and he ran
across the street and that's when they
caught him
so the neighbors caught him yes yes they
caught him and I said on you going to
jail today police came Grandma showed us
the scar from the Teen snatching her
keys the police report said there would
be carjacker left in an ambulance
grandma said she's told he's now in lock
up on 22nd Street he must didn't know
where he was
he didn't know where he was that's what
makes this story so beautiful it's not
just that the grandmother got to keep
her car and make her chemotherapy
appointment it's not just that this
would-be carjacker is now in the Clank
it's not even just that the grandson and
the neighbors who beat the little Thug
to within an inch of his life taught him
a lesson he will not soon forget that
they got to go on with their day while
the punk was hauled off in an ambulance
what is most beautiful
about this story
is that everybody got to see what
community looks like
he didn't know where he was
this would be criminal was not just in
some undifferentiated city as so many of
us increasingly are where Anonymous
individuals fend for themselves with no
ties to one another
he was in a neighborhood
he was in a community and in a community
people know each other in a community
everybody has a role everybody has a
place people trust one another people
look out for one another and as a result
they are able to defend themselves
against predators who wish to do them
harm we used to have a lot of community
here in the United States less and less
every single day maybe we could learn a
lesson from this grandmother in
Washington DC I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday's from El who says
each day Michael's hair gets closer to
God I certainly hope so certainly hope
that's the case
it's a physical representation one hopes
of a metaphysical reality now when you
want to convey these really important
observations to me when you want to
convey any kind of observation to any of
your friends you got to check out pure
talk right now go to puretalk.com use
promo code Knowles given the dreary
economic forecasts that lie ahead you
might be looking for ways to cut back on
spending Pure Talk saves the average
family over 900 a year when they switch
from Verizon ATT or T-Mobile that's
right you can save 900 a year on your
wireless bill and still enjoy Ultra fast
5G service get unlimited talk text in
plenty of data
for just thirty dollars a month Pure
Talk is so sure that you're going to
love your service they're backing it up
with a 100 money back guarantee stop
paying a fortune to Verizon ATT or
T-Mobile cut your bill in half with pure
talk they're us-based customer service
team makes the switch really easy switch
over to Pure talking as little as 10
minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number your first month is
guaranteed risk free I love pure talk I
use Pure Talk Pure Talk saves me a ton
of money on my phone go to puretalk.com
right right now enter promo code nulls
kwles to save 50 off your first month
that is puretalk.com promo code null
skinwalas Pure Talk is simply smarter
Wireless restrictions apply C site for
details
speaking of criminals Sam Brinton do you
remember him Sam Brenton is the former
nuclear waste appointee in the Biden
Administration he's the guy who's a
bald-headed Mustachio dude who
frequently dresses up as a woman who
flaunts his leather puppy fetish he
likes to dress men up as dogs and all
sorts of leather and then do weird
sexual things to them and he likes to
wear lipstick and flowing dresses and
high heels and he was feted by the media
they absolutely loved this guy how
groundbreaking he's a transgender pan
gender whatever gender uh cracking the
glass ceiling and he looks so stunning
he's so brave look at his beautiful
clothing then it turned out
that this guy Sam Brinton is a thief
he got caught stealing luggage at an
airport and initially he said oh I was
this is just a mistake I took the wrong
bag and it turned out he's taken other
bags before then they had camera footage
of him actually looking at the name tags
on the bags and hiding them in his
pocket just going away into and it was
really really weird finally after weeks
and weeks of this it was too much even
for the Biden Administration and so they
canned the guy now we find out
that some of those flowing dresses this
big beautiful
wardrobe pieces that Sam Brenton was
photographed in even including in Vanity
Fair by the way in fashion magazines in
high culture
it it turns out that they were stolen
from specific women there's a woman who
posted on Instagram she said hi I'm a
fashion designer this is a this is a
custom piece that I had made and uh
here's Sam Brinton wearing that piece
and I lost my luggage in 2018 and I'm
not saying for sure it was him but it's
hard to explain how he ended up wearing
my dress if he didn't steal my luggage
so this appears to have been going on
for years
uh he there were other people who came
forward said you know here's me wearing
this unique sort of custom piece and
then you look later on and uh here's Sam
Brinton wearing it shortly after I lost
it and he's being photographed by the
media doing doing the very same thing
making it into magazines so what is this
about
is this because Sam Brinton couldn't
afford clothing I suppose he probably
couldn't afford the high-end clothing
that he'd like to steal but I think it's
about more than that
people can generally purchase clothing
you can go to any inexpensive shop today
and buy any kind of flamboyant clothing
this was obviously some weird fetish for
this guy he's a guy who is most well
known not for his career not for his
knowledge of nuclear waste not for
any virtue or Excellence that he's
engaged in he's most well known for
indulging weird fetishes and it would
seem that stealing women's clothing at
the airport was part of that and it's
it's just a sad lesson that this guy had
a lot of things going for him I'm not
going to say he had everything going for
him but he had a lot of things going for
him he was in an important role in a
presidential Administration he had
impressive academic degrees I think he
went to MIT
but he just couldn't get over this
problem that he had this
actually many
and those
ended up being his undoing and the the
thing you always ask people when they
when they get their comeuppance is was
it worth it
was it worth it the guy who loses his
family because he slept with his
secretary was it worth it you asked the
guys was it worth it they always say no
yes Sam Brenton you lost your job in a
presidential Administration you're now
effectively unemployable certainly at
that height of your profession was it
worth it so that you could wear some
weird red dress that you took from the
airport I assume he would say no
is it worth it to become a laughing
stock internationally so that you can
lead another depraved man around on a
leash in a leather collar was that
really worth it just so that you could
be physically titillated for five
minutes or whatever no but these people
can't escape it this is a real danger
it's it's this joke that Drew tells Drew
Clavin tells about the guy with an
orange for a head the short version of
the joke is guy walks into a bar he's
got an orange for a head the bartender
says okay I gotta ask what's going on he
says all right well you're not gonna
believe it but I was on a beach I find a
little Genie bottle I rubbed the bottle
Genie comes out says I give you three
wishes I said I don't believe that he
says no I do try it he says okay first
wish I won a million dollars knock knock
on the door Pat Sajak here's a check for
a million dollars okay uh
second wish I want to sleep with all the
Playboy bunnies of the Year knock knock
it's all the Playboy bunnies of the year
they walk up isn't that unbelievable
bartender says okay I get it
but had how'd you end up with the orange
he said well here's where I think I
messed up for my third wish I asked to
have an orange for a head
and and half the people think this joke
is hilarious and half the people have no
idea what the joke is about the joke is
about the perversity of the human heart
and how these little weird bizarre
shameful perversions can be people's
undoing Sam Brinton was not the only guy
who dressed in weird vaguely satanic
sometimes not so vaguely satanic ways in
the Biden Administration you remember
the deputy chief of the monkey pox
response Demetrios something or other
was this guy
who
photographed himself flaunted himself
wearing all sorts of satanic imagery
not just leather and whips and chains
pentagrams on his chest a pentagram
leather harness on top of a pentagram
tattoo that the guy put on his chest
you think what is it with this why is it
that we're watching the Grammys and Sam
Smith is dancing around like a kind of
millennial lesbian Satan figure dancing
and jiggling around with all these kind
of demonic looking transsexuals around
him everybody is applauding the first
lady of the United States is in the
audience applauding
why do we see all of this imagery why
are are the the Liberals in New York
raising an actual demon statue on top of
a courthouse in Madison Square why are
they doing that
what what is it about the Symmetry and
then yesterday I see on the cover of
Vogue Italy
Gisele Bundchen Giselle the former Mrs
Brady she's just divorced Tom Brady
Gisele Bundchen considered one of the
most beautiful women in the world and
look at this picture she's
unrecognizable
and what is the picture of it's her in
all red and her her skin is colored all
white just white as a corpse then red
all over her lips her hair has dyed
bright red fiery red as it's being
described in the In Articles a really
really dark around the eyes fiery red
eyebrows
and then
if you look at her head you realize her
head is placed right between the O and
the g
so that you have an almost perfectly
symmetrical lines coming from the O and
the g that are in the placement of and
in the shape of horns and then you look
at her arms and her hand placement and
her arms and her hand placement are in
this very strange way her right arm is
pointed up her hands are in this her
fingers are in this kind of odd
Direction and then her left hand is
pointed to the side not quite down but
certainly further down than
then the right arm
and I don't I don't think I'm going too
far down the rabbit hole here to say
this is a demonic pose everything about
and not just it's demonic
in a pretty uh identifiable way with one
of the most famous depictions of a demon
that would be eliphos levees drawing of
Baphomet many people have seen it
probably the most well-known occult
image and it's of this demon with horns
coming out of his head in the same shape
and uh with wings behind him that are
that we see mirrored on this red dress
that Gisele Bundchen is wearing because
the dress has these kind of wings that
come out of it the arms are in not
exactly the same position but a very
similar position almost the same the
picture of Baphomet is a kind of
transgender picture it's of a goat head
and then breasts a woman's torso and
then a male rest of the body as I'm I
made the point that Media Matters made
fun of me four weeks ago but my
publicists were right were were really
helpful I think in putting this out
there because it was obviously a true
observation that many traditional
depictions of the Demonic are
androgynous and sort of trans and the
question that you got to ask yourself
even if you think all this is really
bizarre and you're not religious and you
don't believe in any of this stuff is
okay let's say let's just pretend for a
second God doesn't exist there's no such
thing as good or evil devil doesn't
exist okay let's pretend all of that
why do all these people dress this way
why do all these people in positions of
power accepted by the liberal culture
why do they all use the exact same
symbolism which is ancient symbolism
which is for
the devil it's it's kind of weird even
if you don't believe in any of this you
never go to church you gotta at least
notice that strange coincidence
that all of these people who are
enthralled to the powers and
principalities of this world they all
use the same images it all looks like
demons I you know I'm like the guy on
the History Channel there's that guy who
he's trying to explain seemingly
inexplicable phenomena that are a little
bit off he'll say well it's it's aliens
it's kind of like that now for me except
it it's demons is what it is now when
you want to protect your body you got to
check out Jace medical right now I go to
jacemedical.com promo code Knowles do
not be caught unprepared have you gone
to the grocery store and not been able
to find something as simple as eggs
just no egg is there in the grocery
store like happened to sweet little
Elise a couple weeks ago then maybe you
go back you do find them they're almost
nine dollars per dozen there are
shortages you should be concerned
shortages don't just happen during
crises like Global pandemics or natural
disasters they are happening every day
they seem to be happening more and more
every day you need to be prepared for
them a great way to start preparing is
with the Jace case from Chase medical
the Jace case is a pack of five
different courses of antibiotics that
you can use to treat a whole host of
bacterial illnesses all you've got to do
is fill out a simple online form your
information will be reviewed by a board
certified physician and your medication
will be dispensed by a licensed pharmacy
at a fraction of the regular cost being
prepared not only brings peace of mind
but also helps you save time and money
in the long run go to jacemedical.com
enter code Knowles kwles a checkout for
a discount on your order that is
jacemedical.com promo code Knowles
there's an old line from baudelaire
which is the greatest trick the devil
ever played is to convince us that he
doesn't exist
might be over
that was true
it was true for the scientific post
Enlightenment era
I think the exact quote it's in French
but a good translation is the finest
trick the devil played is to convince
you he doesn't exist
that that is what happened for the last
300 years
before the last 300 years everybody
thought the devil exists and every
culture on Earth for all of human
history
for the last 300 years the devil kind of
went into hiding why did the devil go
into hiding well because
scientism accomplished his goals I think
better than he could scientism convinced
people that God doesn't exist and so the
devil kind of went away but you're
noticing now that there are many more
overt depictions of this weird occult
kind of behavior
why is that I suspect it's because
people are losing their faith in science
I suspect it's because you're seeing the
the tyranny of the fauces of the world
start to crack the authority of modern
Medical Science to give Perfectly
Natural explanations for all the sorts
of phenomena we see that's breaking down
a little bit so I think the devil's
becoming a little more brazen
that's right you can call me crazy but
explain to me all these weird depictions
in fact speaking of the occult and
politics we've got a new presidential
candidate not on the Republican side but
on the Democrat side that would be
Marianne Williamson you might remember
Marianne Williamson she ran in 2020
on the Democrat side and she became most
well known for her description of what's
really going on in the political scene
I assure you I lived in Gross Point what
happened in Flint would not have
happened in Gross Point this is part of
the dark underbelly of American society
the racism the bigotry and the entire
conversation that we're having here
tonight if you think any of this
wonkiness is going to deal with this
dark psychic force of the collectivized
hatred that this President is bringing
up in this country then I'm afraid that
the Democrats are going to see some very
dark days we need to say it like it is
it's bigger than Flint it's all over
this country
that was the line that she got made fun
of for the most but actually it was the
most coherent line that Marianne
Williamson's probably ever said she said
there are dark psychic forces at Play
yeah that's basically true yeah of
course there's a spiritual reality
undergirding physical phenomena and
there are dark psychic forces dark
spiritual forces at least in politics
now the problem with Marianne Williamson
is she's on the wrong side of it
she's one of these new age occult type
people
but she is recognizing it
she's she's definitely closer to the
truth than the agnostic atheist type
people who say there's no such thing as
metaphysical or spiritual reality well
she's in the race now she says I
wouldn't be running
for president if I didn't believe I
could contribute to harnessing the
collective sensibility that I feel is
our greatest hope at this time
and so all this new agey weird talk but
I'm glad to see her in the race she was
one of my favorite characters from 2020
and I seriously like Beyond just how
entertaining she is I like that she
reminds people that as Cardinal Manning
pointed out all human conflicts
certainly all politics is ultimately
religious speaking of people who want to
be president Pete Buddha judge finally
made it
to East Palestine Ohio this is three
weeks after that train derailment
that sent all sorts of poison spewing
into the air into the ground potentially
affecting the water
judge finally makes it there a day after
Donald Trump showed up in East Palestine
and made a big to do big rally brought
lots of supplies bought people
McDonald's made fun of the Biden
Administration demanded that the bite
Administration shows up finally we get
Mayor Pete
there's a lot of trauma in this
community a lot of emotion and as you
noted a lot of politics too now that
you've seen the wreckage and spoken to
the people was it a mistake not to come
here sooner but what I tried to do was
balance two things my desire to be
involved and engaged and on the ground
which is uh how I am uh generally wired
to act and my desire to follow the norm
of Transportation secretaries allowing
NTSB to really lead the initial stages
of the public facing work I'll do some
thinking about whether I got that
balance right but I think the most
important thing is first of all making
sure that the residents here have what
they need
oh yeah well I was really torn because I
wanted to completely ignore all of you
people you disgusting uh bitter clinging
Bible thumping flyover deplorable
irredeemable people I wanted to totally
ignore your plight but then the former
president Donald Trump showed up
yesterday and brought you all some water
and bought you McDonald's and so now
I've got to come down here and and pose
for photos in a construction hat and a
orange vest like a dime store David Hodo
from the Village People so uh that's
what that's the reason uh that I'm here
right now can I please leave yet I
actually am about to break out in hives
from having to be around all of you
disgusting peasants huh
it's so pathetic if you look at the
pictures of Pete bootage Edge
who speaks well I actually want to be
fair and give credit where credit is due
he is perfectly glib
he has an answer for everything it's not
the most persuasive answer but he gives
the answer in exactly the same kind of
self-assured and soothing and almost
almost uh hypnotizing way that all
management Consultants speak huh well
you know we're just going to uh we're
going to create some more efficiencies
and some new processes for our systems
here at this organization so that we can
have a little bit more Synergy between
all the Departments and he ends the
sentence you say what did you say did
you just say anything but he's very good
at that but it just looks ridiculous
especially him in the hard hat and the
glasses and the vest it just looks so
absurd he obviously doesn't want to be
there he doesn't belong there he doesn't
like these people he doesn't he just
doesn't fit in
Trump however
paradoxically this billionaire playboy
from New York
fits in with these people these are his
people
Trump standing in the McDonald's talking
to the cashier about how he knows the
menu much better than she does passing
out hats talking about how great it was
that the manager made Egg McMuffins for
the people and mocking the Biden
Administration he's and and Trump was
asked
hey what did you bring here to East
Palestine he says I brought the federal
government
boom just walks out much more authentic
I'm somewhat skeptical of the importance
of authenticity and politics
authenticity and everything we're in an
age right now that is obsessed with
being true to your authentic self no I
think you should be true to goodness and
virtue and truth and beauty and God you
should that's what you should be true to
many of the things that you could be
authentic about when it comes to your
own desires are actually pretty harmful
however
in politics
there's something to be said for knowing
your lane knowing your place not trying
to pretend to be somebody else you
remember in 2016. Donald Trump
absolutely destroying all of the other
candidates because Trump is very funny
and he's a showman and so you got lion
lion Ted and low energy jab and Little
Marco and he's making fun of disgusting
John Kasich and he's making fun of all
these people and most of them were smart
enough not to punch back too hard
because it's a losing proposition Little
Marco tried to do it Marco Rubio tried
to push back and do his own Rickles
routine at Donald Trump about how Trump
has small hands and you know what that
means and it just fell completely flat
it fell completely flat it was the first
time that I started to think huh Trump
might have his mojo back Trump might
have his his quick response back his
Showbiz feel his he's there you know I
am is skeptical of how the 2020 election
was conducted as anybody and I've been
pretty clear about that and it's a
difference between me and a lot of other
prominent conservatives is I totally
grant that there were a ton of
shenanigans and rigging and I'm very
skeptical of what happened on Election
night
however
I think this Ohio episode proves Trump
needs to stop harping on the 2020
election and he needs to start talking
about the Forgotten men and women of
America again and that's going to be how
he wins 2024. if he focuses on how he
lost 2020 or it was stolen from him or
whatever it's just
people don't care even people who agree
with that just don't really care that
much anymore but if he talks about the
Forgotten men and women who to judge and
Joe Biden want nothing to do with and he
goes and gives him water and hands them
out Big Macs that's going to be much
much more persuasive much more authentic
you know tomorrow
yes or no the greatest interview show on
the internet is back with a new episode
with our very own Ben Shapiro
that's right it finally happened Ben and
I had a great time duking it out over
drinks testing our knowledge as members
of The Daily wire family you may not
have friends or family as quick-witted
as Ben Shapiro who can own so many
people with facts and logic but you can
still bring the fun home with yes or no
the game currently half the country has
no accountability or ability to reason
and it's just a coincidence half of the
people are women
[Music]
ah this is such a this is such a trap
right here okay okay all right one two
three
[Music]
thank you
it's offensive it's unsafe it's
conspiratorial it's a great time to play
with up to nine people you can determine
where you all land on the most
compelling controversies and greatest
ills of modern society this is a high
quality game we've put it together
there's a lot of fun it's a great way to
spice up your parties it's sold out
before and it'll sell out again so
pre-order now to secure your copy go to
dailywire.com shop today also
you know the great thing about Jordan
Peterson is he dispenses all of his
wisdom with tough love in equal measure
you'll find plenty of both in his new
five-part series out on daily wire plus
called vision and Destiny the series is
designed to help you find Clarity and
direction this is badly needed a lot of
people have no idea who they are
especially when it comes to sex gender
here is a clip from vision and Destiny
explaining that
what is gender well it's what people
feel they are it's like yeah that's your
theory eh that's a stupid Theory there's
it's not going anywhere that theory and
so that's that's just a theory that
enables you to claim something like the
Primacy of your narcissistic whim it has
nothing to do with the careful
delineation of what actually constitutes
identity
and so it's complex because there are
there is variability in masculinity and
femininity
on top of the binary biological
substructure and so that also means that
you have to have a certain amount of
tolerance for role variability and you
should because there are masculine women
and there are feminine men and it's
harder for them in some real sense to
adopt the rule that would be easily
commensurate with their biological
identity because they share many
features
temperamental features that are
characteristic of the opposite sex but
that doesn't mean that they're born in
the wrong body
the first two episodes are out right now
new episodes are coming online every
week it's all exclusive for daily wire
Plus members join now at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch vision and Destiny
speaking of the Biden Administration
green Jean Pierre White House Press
Secretary is now bragging about how few
white people work for Joe Biden
I want to take the opportunity to to lay
out what how diverse the president's
cabinet has been how diverse the
president's Administration has been the
cabinet is majority people of color for
the first time in history the cabin is a
majority female for the first time in
history a majority of white house senior
staff identify as female 40 percent of
White House senior staff identify as
part of the racially diverse communities
and a record seven assistance to the
president are openly lgbtq plus so again
this is something that the president
Prides himself on that he actually has
taken action to show the diversity of
this Administration
thank you
I'm no math expert I haven't quite
crunched all the numbers but
it seems like a lot
I'm not saying it's necessarily bad that
it's a lot of non-white people and gay
people and women and this but
the whole argument for that was that we
need these roles to be representative of
the population
however the numbers that she just put
out are not representative
but the number she just showed is that
if if more than half of the cabinet is
not white then that's not representative
of the American public the American
public is still over 60 percent White
if she's saying that seven special
assistants to the president are LGBT
identifying that's way higher than the
number of people who identify as LGBT in
the general population
so I'm not saying necessarily that's a
bad thing but why is it a good thing
why is it the sort of thing you brag
about
because if it were the other way if she
came out and she said listen 9 out of 10
people who work for this Administration
they're white guys okay we want to
assure you this is the most white
Administration that we have ever had in
America
if she had said that it would be public
outrage there'd be calls for for Joe
Biden's head on a pike
because it wouldn't represent the
population
but the current Biden Administration is
not representative
and they're bragging about that because
obviously the real motivation here is
not to have
our institutions reflect the racial or
sexual or
whatever make up of the people
it's just
that our popular culture hates white
people
it's that our at least our ruling
culture
hates white people hates dudes hates
conservatives
hates Christian people hates anyone who
likes tradition in any way
and I I promise you they would not be
bragging about how how many black or
female cabinet members they have if one
of those cabinet members was Clarence
Thomas if one of this Clarence cabinet
members rather was Candace Owens they
would not be bragging about that because
neither Clarence Thomas nor Candace
Owens are considered black and Candace
is not considered a woman because they
don't they don't check those boxes so
they they they use these
these kind of racial and sexual politics
in a way that is now just overtly
anti-white anti-man
anti-christian anti-jew anti-muslim when
you see the touting of LGBT
that's very bad
we should I know conservatives don't
even want to address that they say oh
well here we go again we should address
that that's really wrong it's really
wrong for our our public figures for our
institutions for the president of the
United States and his spokesman to just
openly come out and say yeah we want as
few white people as we can possibly get
we want as few men as we can possibly
get we want as few people who follow a
traditional sexual ethic as we can
possibly get that's wrong that's very
bad it's a bad thing and we should we
should say it we should not be afraid to
say it for fear of being called racist
or sexist or thisist or phobic or
whatever all the nonsense terms they use
who cares who cares what those people
think who cares what the left calls us
it isn't true first of all isn't true
that we don't like black people isn't
true that we don't like women it isn't
it isn't true even if you view
homosexuality with moral program it
isn't even true that you don't like
those people so who cares what the libs
say about you I certainly don't
I said it was very freeing not to care
about that
they look ridiculous oh my goodness one
of the biggest representatives of this
of this anti-white
anti-christian
anti-American anti-tradition
anti-conservative ideology is this woman
Angela Davis she's a communist terrorist
who has implicated in the murder of four
people and now she's fed it on the left
she's an actual avert communist I'm not
just calling her Pingo she's an actual
open communist and she's been feted by
the radical left for many many decades
now well she just found out
that Angela Davis's lineage
is a little more complicated than she
let on
any idea what you're looking at
that is a list of the passengers on the
Mayflower
no I can't believe this no my ancestors
did not come here on the Mayflower your
ancestors came on the Mayflower no no no
you are descended from one of the 101
people who sailed on the Mayflower
oh
that's a little bit too much
to deal with right now did you ever in
your wildest dreams think that you may
have descended from people who laid
never the foundation never for this
country never never
know and by the way it wasn't just Andy
Mayflower passenger it was William
Brewster that she descended from who is
one of the most prominent members of the
whole Mayflower Voyage in the Plymouth
Colony I Googled it because I also had
to send from Mayflower people I said no
no please no no don't let me who did she
descend from please don't tell me I'm
cousins with Angela oh okay I'm not
cousins with Angela Davis I'm very
pleased to report but Angela Davis is
going to try to cover this up as much as
she can she does she doesn't want to
talk about how she's descended from the
Mayflower because if she does it's going
to complicate her story
is she still going to be able to
complain about all the terrible people
who founded America and how they're evil
and racist and bigoted and this and that
she descends from them maybe she could
the one way that she could
is
she'd have to hate her ancestors
which is actually what leftism is all
about a wise friend of mine explained to
me once that leftism essentially boils
down to screw you Dad
that's what leftism is
the leftist people that that are in your
life I bet 99 out of 100 of them hate
their father their literal actual father
just one generation up they certainly
hate their ancestors they certainly hate
their past that's what it boils down to
and so in a way this is very very
fitting it probably won't change a thing
about Angela Davis's communist advocacy
yeah she's descended from these people
and she hates them she hates her her
forebears in her past just like all the
other Libs do
before we get to the mailbag speaking of
genealogy really really great news hb1
and sb1 just passed in the Tennessee
State House this is the protecting
children from genital mutilation gender
mutilation act prevents minors in
Tennessee from initiating transgender
related puberty blockers cross-sex
hormones and surgeries
really really good news it means that if
you don't want kids to be chemically
castrated you don't want kids to be
mutilated you don't want kids to be
sterilized this is a really great step
in the right direction and you might
recall that our pal Matt Walsh went down
and testified at the State House about
how important these sorts of things are
all of which is to say we've we've all
talked about this stuff for a very long
time
the mission of the daily wire is
from the public or from the private
sector rather to change culture
we're not out there passing laws we're
not out there running for office we're
in the culture we're making movies we're
putting shows out every day we're
throwing rallies Matt held a huge I mean
Matt obviously talks about
transgenderism constantly he had the
what is a Woman movie Matt went out had
the rally to end the mutilation of
children he
has been very focused on that daily wire
puts out what is a woman we've we've
changed the culture a lot and we can
only do that because of you so it's you
really it's really your dollars when you
join you become a member of daily wire
you can see great cultural effects and
then Andrew Breitbart famously would say
politics is Downstream of culture
sometimes when you get enough going on
in the culture sometimes you see Ripple
effects in politics and that can be a
great thing
you know this mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter code Knowles kwlesd at 50 off
your first month
take it away
hey Michael first of all I have to say
thank you for the various shout outs
you've given my late father Hal Rainey
who wrote and voiced the morning in
America campaign for Ronald Reagan now
for my question
I got sober two years ago and that's
when I started to believe in God fast
forward a year later and I meet an
amazing Catholic man who strengthens my
faith even more in whom I was lucky
enough to marry last Saturday
together we go to church every week I
pray daily attend Faith formation
classes and I'm on the Women's Club
board at our church
here's the problem I still don't totally
believe in everything the Bible says I
want to but I was born and raised in the
Church of liberalism AKA San Francisco
and it all still feels so foreign to me
I want to be United with my husband and
our future children who will of course
be raised Catholic so Michael can I or
should I convert even if I'm not a True
Believer at this point merely an
aspiring one or should I wait and if so
what more do you suggest I do to help
push me closer to the word of God in the
words of my father via Bartles and James
thank you for your support
first of all that is so cool about your
father morning in America is one of the
all-time great political advertisements
that's fabulous and then very cool
what's going on in your life
you're saying now I don't totally
understand everything I still have lots
of questions and some hold UPS should I
though I'm I'm drawn to church I'm drawn
to God so should I take that leap and be
baptized or confirmed or part of the
church
yes of course you should is a great line
from Saint John Henry Newman on this
issue
John Henry Newman wrote 10 000
difficulties do not make one doubt
you have questions about the church
because you now were raised in the
Church of liberalism you've converted or
you're in the process of converting and
you're so drawn to the real Church you
say but I don't understand everything
yeah and you're not going to you're not
going to if you could comprehend every
single thing about the faith if you
could comprehend God he wouldn't be God
if you could comprehend every single
thing about the the church well by golly
that would put you ahead of
I guess just about every Bishop every
Pope every doctor of the church every
Theologian every
no it's much greater than you
and ten thousand difficulties do not
make one doubt
you especially see this with the
Catholic faith though certain Protestant
denominations would would get this too
Eastern Orthodoxy would get this too
and John Henry Newman's a good example
here because John Henry Newman was a
Protestant and then as in the Oxford
movement he he converts and becomes
Catholic priest and then a cardinal and
then a saint
the question is where is the authority
are you one of these people who says
well I have to perfectly rationally
understand every single thing myself and
Discover it myself in order for me to
believe that it is true if so a lot of
people feel that way these days but if
so you were still in the thrall of
liberalism and rationalism and modernity
it's a very popular view but it's a very
silly View
or
you have the opinion that you understand
many things you want to examine many
things yourself you have your own
conscience you have your own rational
faculties but you're not going to
understand everything and so you defer
in in certain matters to the wisdom of
the ages and you accept the authority of
the church in particular on certain
questions and then your understanding
will catch up with your belief over time
and if it really doesn't I suppose you
could apostasize but I strongly suspect
that it will catch up over time but it's
simply a fact that the church even by
virtue of just existing for 2000 years
is going to
have a lot of things to know about it to
know about her and you are going to take
a little while to understand that but
you can accept the authority of the
church you can accept
God you can you can believe these things
before you totally understand them
because you'll never totally you'll
never totally understand them but you
will
see them more and more clearly every day
wonderful wonderful news okay next
question
hey Michael knows I just wanted to get
your opinion on the fact that my
girlfriend is pregnant and I am 17 years
old I have
been living in with my grandmother I
live with my brother also take care of
my brother any advice thank you
okay pal first thing
take a deep breath
first thing don't do anything
because that's a very scary situation I
am sure
and so when people are in really scary
situations where they feel very
threatened that's that's when we can
take rash action and are more inclined
to do immoral things that's when we're
most susceptible to falling into that
just take a deep breath
you know I suspect since you're calling
in with this question you know I am not
going to tell you to go down to the
Planned Parenthood clinic and go get an
abortion a lot of people are tempted to
do that and they're tempted to do that
because they mistakenly believe that if
they just go down there and kill the
baby then we can all just pretend this
never happened if we just if I just
hurry and go do this it's like it never
happened
take a breath
catch up with what is going on in
reality right now
you have a child
you currently have a child there's no
one doing it there's no going back
there's no putting the whiskey back in
the bottle and
you have a child
I don't know exactly where you are in
life there are some not very many but
some 17 year olds who are ready to go
strike out on their own and get a job
and
I don't know start a business raise a
family there are some not very many are
capable of doing that today but I do
know some in fact one of my bosses did
that very same thing
right around that age
so maybe you're that kind of guy maybe
you are not capable of taking care of a
child right now and maybe your
girlfriend is also not capable of taking
care of a child right now
in which case adoption would be a real
plausible option
however
you have to also consider this is your
child and sometime down the line you
might think wow I wish I had raised my
child you may think that I don't know I
don't know your situation I don't know
your girlfriend's situation only you
know that
so now that you're thinking of all these
things you're sitting on the bed you're
taking the deep breaths
the the next public thing you should do
next thing you should do once you leave
your room is talk to your girlfriend
about that okay
what do you want to do what are you
thinking or are you
if your girlfriend says I want to get an
abortion say don't do that do not do
that
if your girlfriend says I don't want to
raise a child I'm not going to raise a
child right now I don't want to get
married I don't want to do any of these
things and she's absolutely firm about
that and she says we're going to get an
abortion or this then you then maybe say
no abortion but
maybe adoption or crisis pregnancy
centers or wonderful crisis pregnancy
centers available I can tweet at me
tweet at me send me an email I can give
you a list of them
maybe your girlfriend says I don't want
to give the baby up for adoption I want
to raise the baby okay
if that is what's going to happen you
should get married
and it'll be very hard and you're not
gonna have a lot of money and you're
going to have to go to school and you're
going to have to or some kind of
education program and you're gonna have
to get a job and you're gonna have to
scrimp and save and work very hard and
try to get a lot of money but it's been
done before you can do that
you should also make sure that your
girlfriend understands the reality right
now you both have a baby
two options Available to You Are
give the baby up for adoption which can
be a beautiful wonderful thing
get married raise the baby
I can't give you the answer on which of
those two things to do
but those those are the two options do
not just have the baby and then maybe
consider getting married in five years
don't do that don't get an abortion
don't if you are going to raise the baby
don't
should be a degenerate and go out all
the time and act like a 17 year old that
is foreclosed to you you cannot do that
anymore you have to act like a grown man
and an adult
look those two options dead straight in
the face
and and think about yourself 10 years 20
years from now and what you're gonna not
just what 17 year olds scared
terrified shocked you once but also
think about 27 year old you
37 year old you
and you might come to the conclusion and
say it would be better for the baby and
for us if I give this baby up for
adoption right and I will accept the
regret that will come with that later or
that may come with that later or you
might say no I don't want to give up my
first child for adoption
but that means I I'm not going to get to
behave like a degenerate teenager and
I'm not going to get to go have other
girlfriends and I'm going to have to get
married I'm gonna have to settle down
I'm gonna have to grow up real quick
those are your two options and then pick
one and stick with it next question
hello Nostradamus daily wire pseudonym
Jason Todd from Connecticut thank you
for taking my question the question is
if you could ask Satan any one question
what would it be and why
this question came to me when I was
listening to Young Heretics and Spencer
Clavin was talking about Paradise Lost
and I was asking myself this question
but for me it has always been rather
vindictive along the lines of how is the
making a heaven Out of Hell and Hell Out
of Heaven thing going buddy and then I
chuckled myself so I was wondering if
you had a more
cogent and reasoned question for the
prince of wise and father evil and the
prince of this world thank you
I'm going to ask you to think about that
last part of your question
he said I wanted to know if you have you
know more cogent or interesting question
for the father of Lies
and Prince of evil in this world why
would I have a question for the father
of Lies what what good could possibly
come out of that
what truth could come out of a question
that I pose to the father of Lies
what good could come out of talking to
the prince of evil
nothing I don't want anything to do with
Satan I don't want to talk to Satan I
don't want to look at Satan I don't want
Satan to know my name I just I don't
want anything from him
I reject Satan and all his evil works
and all his empty promises go away I
don't want it you know it's funny ever
since the Sam Smith thing demons and the
devil have come up now and again in
commentary and on this show and
I go back to what C.S Lewis said about
this you have to think about demons
enough to remember that they exist
because it's a real threat just like you
want to remember that lions and tigers
and bears and cockroaches exist
just to kind of guard yourself against
them say oh no okay I gotta put trap
back out here all right let's get out of
here but you don't want to think about
them too much that can be an even worse
problem
I think about demons like cockroaches
actually
I just think they're gross I don't want
them near me they actually can pose kind
of health health threats over time
demons can pose much more of a threat
obviously than cockroaches can but
they're just kind of these just ugly
disgusting things and I just don't want
anything to do with them I don't want to
be near them and I want to look and just
grow gross go away okay I want one more
voicemail back question
I come to call upon Nostradamus for this
particular question conservatives have
been floating the idea of putting in
competency tests for any public official
over the age of 70 who wants to remain
in office or run for re-election or run
for election for the first time I'm
Nikki Haley recently floated this as
part of her announcement that she was
running for president
and I just wanted to see if you could
give a vision into your future
of how you think that'll be implemented
because my question is who's writing the
tests
because the way that our whole
bureaucracy has been run by the left for
decades at this point
I can easily see a scenario where
there's a question on this test about
for example transgenderism
and if you don't toe the left line on
transgenderism maybe they decide you're
not fit to be in office yeah
so is that something you see happening
in the future or am I just a crazy kooky
conspiracy theorist
yeah I don't like the idea of the age
tests the competency tests for President
we have an age and competency test it's
called an election you you run and if
you do better than the other candidates
then
you you passed you passed the test you
get you get the nomination and then you
get to run
the reason that this idea is coming up
now is because the leading Republican
candidate for president is Donald Trump
and he's older I mean he's a young
vibrant man in his own words but he's
older and so the younger candidates are
just using this attack on him because
it's convenient I think
I think when the candidates who are
proposing this is not just Nikki other
candidates have proposes other pundits
have proposed this but I think once
they're older they're not going to be
calling for these competency tests quite
so much so
yeah I don't I don't like the idea we
have a competency test that's why I'm
skeptical of term limits too we have
term limits it's called an election
people can vote if they don't like the
person they can throw the person out
they don't uh by the way whatever you
want to say about Trump
the guy is more competent
he's got more energy than many
politicians
half or two-thirds of his age so yeah
Biden's got his own problems Biden was
not the brightest bulb even 10 years ago
I don't think it's an age problem the
rest of the show
continues now
we are going into fake headline Friday
I need your help help me identify the
fake headline among the real headlines
of Mr Davies has given me you don't want
to miss it go to dailyword.com
use code nulls at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]